This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The Great Slate podcast One Year tells stories of the people and struggles that changed America, One Year at a Time. In each episode, host Josh Levine explores a story that you may have forgotten or have a skewed memory of because you never knew the full context, or maybe something you never even heard of before. They cover everything from the challenger explosion to that time someone discovered an image skewed memory of because you never knew the full context, or maybe something you never even heard of before.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。Slate旗下的播客节目《One Year》讲述了那些改变美国的人和奋斗故事，一年一个主题。在每一集中，主持人乔什·莱文（Josh Levine）都会探索一个你可能已经遗忘，或者因为从未了解完整背景而记忆偏差的故事，又或者是一些你从未听说过的事情。他们涵盖了从挑战者号航天飞机爆炸到有人在玉米饼上发现耶稣画像等各种内容。
They cover everything from the challenger explosion to that time someone discovered an image of Jesus in a tortilla. It's really smart and well made, and one of those shows that I'll hear an episode of, and I'll think, oh man, it would have been fun to report that story. It's done four seasons, each covering a different year, 1977, 1995, 1986, and 1942. The 1942 season is the most recent and had a lot of stories that resonated with what's going on in the world today. It's an episode from that set that I want to share. It's called The Day the Music Stopped. Hey, this is Josh Levine, the host of One Year.
他们涵盖了从挑战者号航天飞机爆炸到有人在玉米饼上发现耶稣画像等各种内容。这档节目非常聪明且制作精良，每当我听完一集，我都会想：“天哪，能报道这个故事该多有趣啊。”该节目已经制作了四季，每一季涵盖不同的年份：1977年、1995年、1986年和1942年。1942年这一季是最近的一季，其中有很多故事与当今世界正在发生的事情产生了共鸣。我想分享这一季中的一集，题目是《音乐停止的那一天》。嘿，我是乔什·莱文，《One Year》的主持人。
This week we have a story from senior producer Evan Chung. In the final days of July 1942, as American factories were ramping up production, one industry was busier than ever. Recording studios were booked solid for days and nights too. Producers and performers were working around the clock, churning out future hit after future hit, like this wartime classic recorded on July 28th by Spike Jones and his city slickers.
本周我们带来的是资深制作人埃文·钟（Evan Chung）的故事。1942年7月的最后几天，随着美国工厂开足马力进行生产，一个行业比以往任何时候都更加繁忙。录音棚日夜不停地被预订一空。制作人和表演者们夜以继日地工作，不断推出一首又一首未来的热门歌曲，比如这首由斯派克·琼斯（Spike Jones）和他的“城市滑头乐队”（City Slickers）于7月28日录制的战时经典。
When the purer says, we used to master ace, we hired, hired, riding the purer space not too long. The next day, Connie Boswell was in the studio tracking a romantic ode to rationing. Not every song made in this recording frenzy was propaganda. The week began with sessions by Judy Gar me and my gal. The week began with sessions by Judy Garland and Jean Kelly. There were recordings by Cab Callaway and Count Basie. Benny Goodman was cutting records that week too,
当纯粹的人说，我们过去常掌握王牌，我们雇佣，雇佣，骑在纯粹的空间里没多久。第二天，康妮·博斯韦尔（Connie Boswell）在录音棚里录制了一首关于配给制的浪漫颂歌。并非这场录音狂潮中制作的每一首歌都是宣传品。这一周以朱迪·加兰（Judy Garland）和吉恩·凯利（Gene Kelly）的录音环节开始。还有卡布·卡洛威（Cab Calloway）和贝西伯爵（Count Basie）的录音。本尼·古德曼（Benny Goodman）那周也在录制唱片。
so we're Bing Crosby and Dynas Shore. Ella Fitzgerald got in on the act on July 31, along with Lester Young, Woody Herman, and Harry James. And then, on August 1st, nothing. Every recording studio in America went silent. They stayed silent the next day, and the next. The music didn't start up again the following week, the following month, or the following year. This wasn't because of wartime austerity. It was because the musicians of America had collectively
平·克劳斯贝（Bing Crosby）和黛娜·肖尔（Dinah Shore）也是如此。艾拉·费兹杰拉（Ella Fitzgerald）在7月31日加入了这一行列，还有莱斯特·杨（Lester Young）、伍迪·赫尔曼（Woody Herman）和哈里·詹姆斯（Harry James）。然后，到了8月1日，一切都停止了。美国所有的录音棚都陷入了沉默。第二天，以及接下来的日子里，它们依然保持沉默。音乐并没有在接下来的一周、一个月或一年里重新响起。这不是因为战时的紧缩政策，而是因为美国的音乐家们集体
walked off the job. New technology was threatening their livelihoods, so they launched one of the most consequential union actions in the nation's history, a total ban on recording that cut off the country's supply of new songs. But underground, artists were developing something revolutionary, and when the ban finally ended, American music would find itself transported into a whole new era. This is one year 1942. The day the human voice. It's a man singing, captured on a device called a phonotogram in 1860.
罢工了。新技术正在威胁他们的生计，于是他们发起了美国历史上最具影响力的工会行动之一：全面禁止录音，切断了全国新歌的供应。但在地下，艺术家们正在开发一些革命性的东西，当禁令最终结束时，美国音乐将发现自己被带入了一个全新的时代。这是《One Year》1942年特辑。那一天，人类的声音。这是一个男人在唱歌，1860年被一种叫“声波记录仪”（phonoautogram）的设备捕捉到。
This is a very, very, very, auspicious moment because when we think about sound, it's typically accorded with the powers of the gods in ancient societies. Tim Anderson is a media scholar at Old Dominion University, so there's something God-like about this. When humans harness the power to record sound, it upended our 40,000-year-old understanding of what music is. Music had always been a performance that dissipates the moment it hits the air. We don't usually consider that history when we play a song.
这是一个非常、非常、非常吉祥的时刻，因为当我们想到声音时，它通常在古代社会中被赋予了神的力量。蒂姆·安德森（Tim Anderson）是老道明大学（Old Dominion University）的媒体学者，所以这其中有一种神圣感。当人类掌握了录制声音的力量时，它颠覆了我们对音乐4万年来的理解。音乐一直是一种在触及空气的瞬间就会消散的表演。当我们播放一首歌时，我们通常不会考虑那段历史。
We are not thinking about how tremendously odd this is and how tremendously powerful it is. You're basically regenerating life. At the turn of the century, recorded music became an industry. That's when songs began to be pressed onto shellac discs. Records allowed musical performances to be mass reproduced, so that in 1904, more than a million people could bring the tenor and rico-coruso into their homes.
我们没有考虑到这是多么离奇，又是多么强大。你基本上是在再生生命。世纪之交，录音音乐成为了一种产业。那时，歌曲开始被压制在虫胶唱片上。唱片使得音乐表演可以被大规模复制，以至于在1904年，超过一百万人可以将男高音恩里科·卡鲁索（Enrico Caruso）带入他们的家中。
When listeners gained the magical ability to bottle up and uncork musicians on demand, what did it mean for the musicians themselves? As the recording industry continued to grow, some performers began to worry that power was being taken away from them. If you are playing live, you're playing for a specific audience. You have a connection with them, and you control the output. But the minute you put your voice for your song on record, you've already given that up. For some musicians, anxiety about recording technology would turn into outright hostility. And one person's hatred for canned music topped them all. about recording technology, return into outright hostility.
当听众获得了按需装瓶和开启音乐家的神奇能力时，这对音乐家本人意味着什么？随着录音产业的不断增长，一些表演者开始担心权力正在被剥夺。如果你在现场演奏，你是为特定的观众演奏。你与他们有联系，并且你控制着输出。但一旦你把你的声音或歌曲录制成唱片，你就已经放弃了这一点。对于一些音乐家来说，对录音技术的焦虑会演变成彻底的敌意。而一个人对罐头音乐的仇恨超过了所有人。
And one person's hatred for canned music topped them all. He is the boss of the nation's musicians. Mr. James Caesar Petrillo, the president of the American Federation of Musicians. I am satisfied that if the public of America knew the fight of musicians, knew what he's up against, that the public senate would immediately change. ["The Future of the World"]
而一个人对罐头音乐的仇恨超过了所有人。他是全国音乐家的老板。詹姆斯·凯撒·佩特里洛（James Caesar Petrillo）先生，美国音乐家联合会（American Federation of Musicians）主席。“我相信，如果美国公众了解音乐家的斗争，了解他所面临的困境，公众的看法会立即改变。”
James Cesar Petrilo, there's something very big and brassy to me, he's like so Chicago. James Cesar Petrilo was born in 1892 and grew up on Chicago's west side. His father was a sewer digger from Italy, and he had a hard-scrabble childhood. According to legend, Jimmy once got into a fight with nine boys and defeated them all one after the other over the course of two hours. He quit school after the fourth grade. By then, he already found his calling.
詹姆斯·凯撒·佩特里洛，对我来说，他身上有一种非常宏大且张扬的东西，他太“芝加哥”了。詹姆斯·凯撒·佩特里洛出生于1892年，在芝加哥西区长大。他的父亲是一名来自意大利的下水道挖掘工，他度过了一个艰难的童年。根据传说，吉米曾经在两个小时内与九个男孩打架，并一个接一个地击败了他们。他在四年级后就辍学了。到那时，他已经找到了自己的使命。
Petrilo grew up as part of this musician's union he was a trumpeter. Just not a very good one. Here he is later in life playing a questionable duet with former President Harry S. Truman on piano. Music may not have been his forte, but musicians were his people. In 1922, he became the president of the Chicago local 10 of the American Federation of Musicians.
佩特里洛在音乐家工会中长大，他是一名小号手。只是水平不太高。这是他晚年与前总统哈里·S·杜鲁门（Harry S. Truman）在钢琴上合奏的一段令人质疑的二重奏。音乐可能不是他的强项，但音乐家是他的同胞。1922年，他成为了美国音乐家联合会芝加哥第10分会的主席。
He quickly imposed discipline, consolidated power, and ruthlessly grew membership. Although he drew the line at the city's black musicians, he refused to let their local merge with his. Taking charge in the Capone era, Petrillo tussled with Chicago's power brokers, theater owners, and other union leaders. His intimidation tactics made him plenty of enemies. In 1924, the windows of his house got blown out by a bomb. When Petrilo took over, it was an exciting time to be a musician. The record industry was growing in popularity, especially after the emergence of much higher quality
他迅速实施纪律，巩固权力，并无情地扩大成员规模。尽管他在该市的黑人音乐家面前划清了界限，拒绝让他们的分会与自己的合并。在卡彭（Capone）时代掌权后，佩特里洛与芝加哥的权力掮客、剧院老板和其他工会领袖进行了斗争。他的恐吓手段让他树敌众多。1924年，他家的窗户被炸弹炸飞了。佩特里洛接手时，正是音乐家们激动人心的时代。唱片业越来越受欢迎，特别是在更高质量的
electrical recording in 1925. But most musicians paid the bills by playing live. And in the 1920s, they had a brand new venue. WLS Chicago D. Series, Robux Station. Let's have a little song. Come on. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Coggo D, series roadbuck station, a little song, come on. Hello, hello, hello. In the early days of radio, the music on most stations came from live performers.
1925年电气录音出现之后。但大多数音乐家靠现场演奏来维持生计。在20世纪20年代，他们有了一个全新的场所。WLS芝加哥西尔斯·罗巴克（Sears Roebuck）电台。来唱首歌吧。来吧。你好。你好。你好。你好。西尔斯·罗巴克电台，来首歌吧，来吧。你好，你好，你好。在广播的早期，大多数电台的音乐都来自现场表演者。
But it was another medium that provided the best work. The movies. With the introduction of silent pictures, musicians became even more important because they provided the soundtrack. They provided a live soundtrack. Robin DG Kelly is a professor of history at UCLA. And this is something that we often take to grant it, what it meant to go to the theater. Going to the movies was going to a concert. A cinema might hire an organist, or a four-piece combo, or a full orchestra. Quite a few of those jobs went to women, and if you were in a black neighborhood, you'd likely see black performers.
但另一个媒介提供了最好的工作。电影。随着默片的引入，音乐家变得更加重要，因为他们提供了配乐。他们提供了现场配乐。罗宾·D·G·凯利（Robin D.G. Kelley）是加州大学洛杉矶分校的历史学教授。这是我们经常认为理所当然的事情，去剧院意味着什么。去看电影就是去听音乐会。电影院可能会雇佣一名管风琴手、一个四人组合或一整个管弦乐队。其中不少工作由女性担任，如果你在黑人社区，你很可能会看到黑人表演者。
Harlan was famous for going to hear someone like Fats Waller, great piano player, you know, make up some music on the spot. His performances were sometimes more the spectacle than the film itself. [♪ Music playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing in background, playing and theaters. There were about 2,000 accompanists in James Petrilo's Chicago alone, and these were coveted gigs. They're tied to a location, they keep you off the road, and if you're working in an orchestra pit making live film scores, you have a job there potentially seven
哈兰（Harlem）以去听像胖子沃勒（Fats Waller）这样伟大的钢琴家即兴创作音乐而闻名。他的表演有时比电影本身更引人注目。在剧院里。仅在詹姆斯·佩特里洛的芝加哥，就有大约2000名伴奏者，这些都是令人垂涎的工作。它们与地点挂钩，让你不必四处奔波，如果你在管弦乐池里为现场电影配乐，你可能每周有七天的工作。
days a week. But then, in 1927, Al Jolson appeared on movie screens. He was in blackface, and in full sound. The movie that jazzed Singer with its tropes drawn From Minstrelsea is an American cultural relic, but it ushered in a new cinematic era of recorded sound tracks. Theater owners rushed to embrace the so-called talkies, and cleared out their orchestra pits. And when we see the rise of early sound cinema and we start to see the decline of these orchestras, this is shocking for many musicians.
但后来，在1927年，阿尔·乔尔森（Al Jolson）出现在电影银幕上。他涂着黑脸，并且有完整的音效。那部电影《爵士歌手》（The Jazz Singer），其桥段取材于吟游诗人表演，是美国文化遗迹，但它开启了一个录制音轨的电影新时代。剧院老板们争先恐后地拥抱所谓的“有声电影”，并清理了他们的管弦乐池。当我们看到早期有声电影的兴起，并开始看到这些管弦乐队的衰落时，这对许多音乐家来说是令人震惊的。
New technology had given them their comfortable lives. And just as quickly, technology had put them on the unemployment line. That's how technology works often, you know. Technology is seen as providing more access, more opportunities, but then also you have that sort of hidden agenda. It's a labor-saving device. You know, but labor-saving device means people lose their jobs.
新技术给了他们舒适的生活。但同样迅速地，技术也让他们失业了。这就是技术通常的工作方式。技术被视为提供了更多的获取途径和机会，但随后你也会发现那种隐藏的议程。它是一种节省劳动力的设备。你知道，但节省劳动力的设备意味着人们失去了工作。
And overnight, some 18,000 musicians were loud. James Petrello was incensed. Here he is in 1948, testifying to Congress about the plight of working performers. So, at that time, the day, sad experience, it was a natural thing for the musicians to try and protect themselves the best we know how. He fought back and tried to force every movie theater in Chicago to employ at least one union organist. When owners refused, some theaters mysteriously went up in flames. Petrillo denied having anything to do with those fires. Ultimately, it didn't matter.
一夜之间，大约18000名音乐家失业了。詹姆斯·佩特里洛感到愤怒。这是他在1948年向国会作证，讲述在职表演者的困境。“所以，在那个时候，那一天，悲惨的经历，音乐家们试图尽我们所知保护自己是很自然的事情。”他进行了反击，试图强迫芝加哥的每一家电影院至少雇佣一名工会管风琴手。当老板们拒绝时，一些剧院神秘地起火了。佩特里洛否认与这些火灾有任何关系。最终，这并不重要。
By the mid-30s, there were only 125 movie theater jobs left for musicians in Chicago. And so this was a huge loss, but it was a loss during the Great Depression, which made matters even worse. Where are you going to go? You know, where are you going to work? Well, okay, we'll go to the bars. But that only lasted so long. Once the restaurants and beer gardens of the nation all had their orchestras, but the mechanical jukeboxes drove them out of work. The jukebox was yet another disruption. During the Depression, cafe owners saw this new technology as a way to cut costs.
到30年代中期，芝加哥只剩下125个电影院工作岗位给音乐家。所以这是一个巨大的损失，但这是在大萧条期间的损失，这让情况变得更糟。你要去哪里？你要去哪里工作？好吧，好吧，我们去酒吧。但这只持续了很短时间。曾经全国的餐馆和啤酒花园都有他们的管弦乐队，但机械点唱机把他们赶出了工作岗位。点唱机是又一次颠覆。在大萧条期间，咖啡馆老板们将这种新技术视为削减成本的一种方式。
You can now stock a box of records and essentially say to the duo or trio there that played on a regular basis, you're not needed. By 1938, the US had at least 200,000 jukeboxes. If you figure a single machine could replace two or three musicians, that's a lot of jobs lost. Things were changing on the radio, too. Stations realized that they could save money by playing records instead of hiring live bands. Musicians who had made recordings were now essentially competing with themselves. It's being utilized against you. You no longer have that job because you made that record. One recording could be heard by millions over and over again. It gives consumers and corporations
你现在可以储备一盒唱片，基本上可以对那些定期演奏的二人组或三人组说，你们不需要了。到1938年，美国至少有20万台点唱机。如果你算上一台机器可以取代两到三个音乐家，那就是大量的工作岗位流失。广播电台的情况也在发生变化。电台意识到，他们可以通过播放唱片而不是雇佣现场乐队来省钱。那些制作过唱片的音乐家现在基本上是在与自己竞争。“它被用来对付你。你不再拥有那份工作，因为你制作了那张唱片。”一张唱片可以被数百万人反复收听。它赋予了消费者和企业
more control over musicians' labor. It cheapens musicians' labor in many ways. And it is traumatic to lose control over your production. And it's a threat, it's disruptive. James C. Petrilo took that threat very seriously. To protect his union members, he pressured radio stations in Chicago to destroy records after playing them just one time. His militant tactics caught the attention of anxious musicians all over the country.
对音乐家劳动的更多控制权。它在许多方面贬低了音乐家的劳动。失去对你作品的控制是痛苦的。这是一种威胁，具有破坏性。詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛非常认真地对待这种威胁。为了保护他的工会成员，他向芝加哥的广播电台施压，要求他们在播放唱片一次后将其销毁。他激进的策略引起了全国焦虑的音乐家的注意。
And in 1940, he got elected the national leader of the American Federation of Musicians in a unanimous vote. So he's elected as president and slowly but surely assembles and moves forward with this idea that we're going to try to counter the nuisance known as canned music. Coming out of the depression, the recording industry was dominated by just three companies, RCA Victor, Columbia, and DECA. Those three labels controlled about 90% of the market.
1940年，他以全票当选为美国音乐家联合会的全国领袖。所以他当选为主席，并慢慢地、坚定地聚集并推进了这个想法，即我们要尝试对抗被称为“罐头音乐”的滋扰。走出大萧条后，唱片业被三家公司主导：RCA Victor、哥伦比亚（Columbia）和迪卡（Decca）。这三家唱片公司控制了大约90%的市场。
And that's who Petrillo decided to target. We've got some power, we're going to put some pressure on it, and we want some changes. On June 8th, 1942, Petrillo spoke at the AFM's annual convention. By then, more than half of the unions 138,000 members were unemployed. He told the delegates, now is the time, that Union musicians would never again play at their own funerals. Why should we record these things
而这正是佩特里洛决定针对的目标。“我们拥有一些权力，我们将施加一些压力，我们想要一些改变。”1942年6月8日，佩特里洛在AFM的年度大会上发表了讲话。到那时，工会13.8万名成员中有一半以上失业了。他告诉代表们，现在是时候了，工会音乐家绝不会再为自己的葬礼演奏。“我们为什么要录制这些会让我们失业的东西？”
that are gonna put us out of our jobs? We're not doing this anymore. He declared that on August 1st, 1942, the musicians of America were going to stop recording, permanently. The crowd of 700 delegates responded with rapturous applause. The fight was on. And Petrillo was confident the record industry would lose.
“我们不再做这件事了。”他宣布，从1942年8月1日起，美国的音乐家将永久停止录音。700名代表组成的群体报以热烈的掌声。战斗开始了。佩特里洛相信唱片业会输。
Why does it take some time for the radio stations and the jukebox to feel the ban on recordings of the American musician, the time is going to come that they're not going to be able to get the records they want and satisfy the American public. That's the long chance we're taking. In the summer of 1942, a letter arrived at every recording studio in America. It said, your license from the American Federation of Musicians for the employment of its members in the making of musical recordings
“为什么广播电台和点唱机需要一些时间才能感受到对美国音乐家录音的禁令？时间会到来，他们将无法获得他们想要的唱片来满足美国公众。这是我们正在冒的长期风险。”1942年夏天，一封信寄到了美国每一家录音棚。信中说：“你从美国音乐家联合会获得的雇佣其成员制作音乐录音的许可
will expire on July 31st, 1942, and will not be renewed. At the bottom was the rubber stamped signature of Jane C. Patrillo. Some thought it was a bluff. It wasn't. As first move in a campaign to share fully in the profits of every commercial use of recorded music, the American Federation of Musicians for bad its members to perform for any recording company. At Petrilo's order, the record business ground to a stop.
将于1942年7月31日到期，且不会续签。”底部是詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛的橡皮图章签名。有些人认为这只是虚张声势。事实并非如此。作为分享录音音乐每一次商业用途利润的运动的第一步，美国音乐家联合会禁止其成员为任何唱片公司表演。在佩特里洛的命令下，唱片业务陷入了停滞。
The band was pretty near total. From Benny Goodman down to the tavern Fiddler, the record companies were left with nobody to record, and they were not happy about it, especially since Petrillo said that he wasn't interested in negotiating. Refusing to set any terms was tactical because if he made demands that would make it sound like the musicians were on strike and after Pearl Harbor labor leaders had pledged not to do that. You have to keep the engines running in this country for the war effort and a
禁令几乎是全面的。从本尼·古德曼到酒馆小提琴手，唱片公司找不到人录音，他们对此并不高兴，尤其是因为佩特里洛说他对谈判不感兴趣。拒绝设定任何条款是战术性的，因为如果他提出要求，听起来就像音乐家在罢工，而在珍珠港事件后，劳工领袖承诺不会这样做。你必须让这个国家的引擎为战争努力运转，而
strike would have been anti-patriotic and you paid a price for doing so. Mark Myers is an author and music critic. He says Petrillo tried to regal out of that pledge by arguing a technicality. Well, you know, it's not really a strike. We're just not going to work in recording studios. If you want to have us on the radio, that's fine. We're just not showing up at this other place. The government didn't think much of that line of reasoning. The US is pretty much looking at this and saying, this is a real problem. The US government really wants this to end. You know, this shuts down economies. Media studies professor Tim Anderson again.
罢工将是不爱国的，这样做会付出代价。马克·迈尔斯（Mark Myers）是一位作家和音乐评论家。他说佩特里洛试图通过争论一个技术细节来摆脱那个承诺。“好吧，你知道，这真的不是罢工。我们只是不在录音棚工作。如果你想让我们在广播里表演，那没问题。我们只是不去那个地方。”政府对这种推理并不买账。美国几乎是在看着这一切并说：“这是一个真正的问题。”美国政府真的希望这一切结束。你知道，这会关闭经济。媒体研究教授蒂姆·安德森再次说道。
There's a real reaction. It's not pro-labor. I mean, it's very much we have to get this under control. The director of the Office of War Information declared the ban a threat to the war effort. He warned that small radio stations that relied on recorded music might shut down, and that those stations were essential for keeping the public up to date. Other government officials said the ban was unpatriotic, that it was wrong to deprive little children of music during wartime. In other words, while Americans had to ration rubber, gas, and coffee, music was a step too far.
“这是一种真正的反应。这不是亲劳工的。我的意思是，这非常像是我们必须控制住局面。”战争情报办公室主任宣布该禁令是对战争努力的威胁。他警告说，依赖录音音乐的小型广播电台可能会倒闭，而这些电台对于让公众了解最新情况至关重要。其他政府官员称该禁令是不爱国的，在战时剥夺小孩子的音乐是错误的。换句话说，当美国人不得不配给橡胶、汽油和咖啡时，音乐被认为太过分了。
Washington's hostility was surprising, considering how friendly the Roosevelt administration had been to the labor movement. It was FDR who had signed the National Industrial Recovery Act and the Wagner Act. By this act employers are bound to bargain collectively with an organized majority of their workers. We take that for granted today, but it codified that workers have this right to organize historian Robin D. G. Kelly. Despite the Great Depression, unions became stronger than they had been really since the 1870s. Many labor strikes, many fights for fair wages, the 40-hour work week, and it's being seen as a remedy to out of control capital.
考虑到罗斯福政府对劳工运动的友好程度，华盛顿的敌意令人惊讶。正是罗斯福签署了《全国工业复兴法》和《瓦格纳法案》。“根据这项法案，雇主有义务与其工人的有组织多数进行集体谈判。”我们今天认为这是理所当然的，但它将工人有权组织起来编纂成法，历史学家罗宾·D·G·凯利说。尽管有大萧条，工会变得比1870年代以来真正强大得多。许多劳工罢工，许多争取公平工资、40小时工作周的斗争，这被视为对失控资本的一种补救。
But during World War II, Washington saw unions as impediments to the war machine, and the public didn't support the musicians either. A Gallup poll showed a 75% disapproval rate, even though many of the people listening to music were laborers themselves. You would think that workers would stand in solidarity with the musicians, but they wanted entertainment, and the struggles and musicians didn't seem to carry the same kind of moral weight as say the struggles of steelworkers. Even today, people have a hard time thinking of
但在第二次世界大战期间，华盛顿将工会视为战争机器的障碍，公众也不支持音乐家。盖洛普民意调查显示，75%的人表示反对，尽管许多听音乐的人本身就是劳动者。你会认为工人们会与音乐家团结一致，但他们想要娱乐，而音乐家的斗争似乎并没有像钢铁工人的斗争那样具有同样的道德分量。即使在今天，人们也很难想到
music as labor, but Petrillo argued that musicians had to be seen as workers just like pipefitters or minersors. The only difference between the minors and the musicians is that the miners didn't make the machine that might destroy that. That argument didn't really catch on with the public. It didn't help that recording companies, broadcasters, and editorial cartoonists were mounting a PR campaign against Petrilo. Oh, in a few short months, found himself the target of an unprecedented barrage of public criticism and became to many the symbol of a laborer's are unbridled and irresponsible.
音乐是一种劳动，但佩特里洛辩称，音乐家必须被视为像管道工或矿工一样的工人。“矿工和音乐家之间唯一的区别是，矿工没有制造出可能摧毁他们的机器。”那个论点并没有真正被公众接受。唱片公司、广播公司和社论漫画家针对佩特里洛发起的公关运动也无济于事。哦，在短短几个月内，他发现自己成为了前所未有的公众批评浪潮的目标，并对许多人来说成为了劳工不受约束和不负责任的象征。
No one was ever more vilified than I have in the President's country if they would spend half of the money, that they spend on cartoons, vilifying me, they would give it to the musicians, and we'd all be happy." One editorial called Petrillo an inflated little non-entity who strong-armed himself into dictatorial power. They quite simply tried to say to them, you know, he's a strong man leader like Mussolini and Hitler. His critics claimed the band wasn't really collective action, but merely an autocrat's
“没有人比我更受诋毁了，如果他们把花在漫画上诋毁我的钱的一半花在音乐家身上，他们会把它给音乐家，我们都会很高兴。”一篇社论称佩特里洛是一个“膨胀的小人物”，他通过强硬手段获得了独裁权力。他们干脆试图对他们说：“你知道，他是一个像墨索里尼和希特勒那样的强人领袖。”他的批评者声称，禁令并非真正的集体行动，而仅仅是一个独裁者的
personal vendetta imposed on reluctant musicians. No, no, I mean, he clearly was the strong person that put it forward, but there was real foam-entined pressure at many different levels. It wasn't just his idea. You know, I think musicians in general were just really, they're really, really upset with what's happening to their labor position. The fact is though, it was easy to lump him into, say, a category like Mussolini or Hitler, because I think he's a character.
强加给不情愿的音乐家的个人恩怨。“不，不，我的意思是，他显然是提出这一点的强人，但在许多不同层面上确实存在着真正的泡沫压力。这不仅仅是他的主意。你知道，我认为音乐家们普遍对他们的劳动地位所发生的事情感到非常、非常不安。”事实是，把他归入像墨索里尼或希特勒这样的类别很容易，因为我认为他是一个有个性的人。
I think, you know, Petrilla really was a character. Now, Mr. Petrilo is a very entertaining gentleman. He's a little man with short stubby arms and pudgy fingers. Sometimes as he speaks in axi, he seems to be a little bit like Chico Marx or perhaps even Jimmy Duranty. A writer for Life magazine described Petrilo as resembling an elderly frog
我想，你知道，佩特里洛确实是一个有个性的人。“现在，佩特里洛先生是一位非常有趣的绅士。他是一个有着短粗手臂和胖乎乎手指的小个子男人。有时当他说话时，他看起来有点像奇科·马克斯（Chico Marx），甚至可能是吉米·杜兰特（Jimmy Durante）。”《生活》杂志的一位撰稿人形容佩特里洛长得像一只老青蛙，
that has just eaten a big and somewhat bitter dragonfly. The Trillo was wisecracking and pugnacious. His personality drew a lot of attention, but it could also detract from his arguments. His critics caricatured him as a luddite, foolishly trying to stand in the way of innovation. There's a real famous cartoon with him writing a dinosaur, this idea that we're going back to the past, and it paints him as somebody who's trying to hold progress back. Petrilla really did seem to hate recording technology, but he wasn't so naive to think
刚刚吃掉了一只又大又苦的蜻蜓。佩特里洛言辞犀利且好斗。他的个性吸引了很多关注，但也可能削弱了他的论点。他的批评者将他描绘成一个卢德分子，愚蠢地试图阻碍创新。有一幅非常著名的漫画，画着他骑着恐龙，这个想法是我们正在回到过去，它把他描绘成一个试图阻碍进步的人。佩特里洛确实似乎讨厌录音技术，但他并不天真到认为
he could just turn back the clock. It's not about harming progress, it's about saying, hey, hold on, hold on a minute. We're progressing, but you're leaving behind all these people, all these laborers that put these records into play. Why aren't they getting paid? Because so few musicians earned a living from recording, they weren't risking much by staying out of the studio.
他可以倒转时钟。“这不是关于损害进步，而是关于说，嘿，等等，等一下。我们正在进步，但你却抛弃了所有这些人，所有这些把这些唱片投入使用的劳动者。为什么他们没有得到报酬？”因为很少有音乐家靠录音谋生，所以他们留在录音棚外并没有冒太大的风险。
So they were committed to holding their ground until they got a fair shake. And the recording industry realized it needed a plan. The record labels began mounting their counteroffensive even before the ban officially started. Well, the first thing they do is they stop pile. They go, okay, well, we know that this is coming down the line. We are going to shove a lot of things in into production and see if we can wait this out. That's where you see that flurry of round the clock recording in the final weeks of July 1942.
所以他们致力于坚守阵地，直到他们得到公平的待遇。唱片业意识到它需要一个计划。唱片公司甚至在禁令正式开始之前就开始发起反攻。“好吧，他们做的第一件事就是囤积。他们说，好吧，好吧，我们知道这即将到来。我们要把很多东西投入生产，看看我们是否能熬过这段时间。”这就是你在1942年7月的最后几周看到的疯狂的昼夜录音。
That stockpile of songs left record companies with plenty of material to trickle out that summer and fall, and even into the holidays. Fortunately for Decker Records, Bing Crosby had recorded White Christmas shortly before the band went into effect. It topped the charts for 11 weeks in 1942 and became the biggest selling single of all time. The stockpile was working, but it wasn't unlimited. And Petrillo was not going to relent anytime soon.
那批歌曲储备让唱片公司有足够的材料在那个夏天和秋天，甚至假期里慢慢发布。幸运的是，对于迪卡唱片公司来说，平·克劳斯贝在禁令生效前不久录制了《白色圣诞节》（White Christmas）。它在1942年登顶排行榜11周，并成为有史以来销量最高的单曲。囤积策略奏效了，但它不是无限的。而佩特里洛也不会很快让步。
The public was going to demand new songs, so the labels began looking for loopholes, ways to evade the band and make new recordings. One of the interesting things about the recording band is it did not affect vocalists. Vocalists didn't belong to the musician's union, only instrumentalist it. Writer Mark Myers again. What does that mean? Well it meant Frank Sinatra could sing, but there was nobody to play music behind them. Ever homework, ever homework.
公众会要求新歌，所以唱片公司开始寻找漏洞，寻找规避禁令并进行新录音的方法。“关于录音禁令，有趣的事情之一是它不影响歌手。歌手不属于音乐家工会，只有器乐演奏者才属于。”作家马克·迈尔斯再次说道。“那意味着什么？好吧，这意味着弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）可以唱歌，但没有人为他演奏音乐。”
Except the record labels realized there were some accompanists they could hire. It wasn't only singers who were left out of the union. There were a handful of musicians that were excluded too, presumably because their instruments were deemed too amateurish, things like Ocarina's, Eucalyles, and Jawharps. The classic examples that harmonica players were not organized. So one of the ways that people got around these bands was actually by recording harmonica acts. The wine in March 20, till I feel like 99. There was another more common way to circumvent the band.
除非唱片公司意识到他们可以雇佣一些伴奏者。不仅仅是歌手被排除在工会之外。还有少数音乐家也被排除在外，大概是因为他们的乐器被认为太业余了，比如陶笛、尤克里里和口簧琴。经典的例子是口琴演奏者没有被组织起来。所以人们绕过这些禁令的方法之一实际上是录制口琴表演。还有另一种更常见的规避禁令的方法。
Producers tried backing their singers with more singers. What they decided to do is create a vocal choir, so that the vocal choir is creating what the instruments would have played, like on this 1942 recording by Ethel Murn. The labels tried out the acapella tactic on a bunch of artists, like Bing Crosby, Dick Haymes, and Perry Como. All the best of love to you. Not very successful.
制作人尝试用更多的歌手来为他们的歌手伴奏。他们决定创建一个声乐合唱团，这样声乐合唱团就能创造出乐器本应演奏的效果，就像埃塞尔·默尔曼（Ethel Merman）在1942年的这张录音中那样。唱片公司在平·克劳斯贝、迪克·海姆斯（Dick Haymes）和佩里·科莫（Perry Como）等一众艺术家身上尝试了这种无伴奏合唱策略。“把所有的爱都给你。”不太成功。
You know, the stuff sounds sort of modland, doesn't sound as peppy and as punchy, but that's how vocalists got around it. It proved to be a short-lived fad, but there is some speculation that this was the origin of the wordless vocals you'd hear all over lounge records in the 50s and 60s. During the ban, there were a handful of exceptions, where James Petrilla would permit instrumentalists to record. This is Captain Glenn Miller speaking for the Army Air Force's training command archter, and we hope the two soldiers of the Allied forces
“你知道，这些东西听起来有点平淡，听起来不像有乐器伴奏那样活泼和有力，但这就是歌手们绕过它的方式。”这被证明是一种短命的时尚，但有一些猜测认为，这就是你在50和60年代的休息室唱片中听到的无词人声的起源。在禁令期间，有少数例外情况，詹姆斯·佩特里洛会允许器乐演奏者录音。“这是格伦·米勒（Glenn Miller）上尉，代表陆军航空队训练司令部管弦乐队发言，我们希望盟军的士兵们
enjoy these V-discs that we're making just for you. V-discs were records distributed exclusively to the troops. But Trillo allowed them on the condition that the soldiers destroy them before coming home. But still, at least temporarily, the military got to hear Frank Sinatra's hit Close to You, backed by a full orchestra. On the home front, all you got was the Achapella version.
喜欢我们专门为你们制作的这些V-唱片（V-discs）。”V-唱片是专门分发给部队的唱片。佩特里洛允许它们，条件是士兵们在回家前销毁它们。但即便如此，至少暂时，军方得以听到弗兰克·辛纳屈的畅销曲《靠近你》（Close to You），并由完整的管弦乐队伴奏。在国内，你只能听到无伴奏合唱版本。
Another exception to the recording band was in Hollywood. The studio orchestras there continued to make movie soundtracks, but that led to some oddities. Take the 1942 film that would go on to win Best Picture. There's a famous scene in Casablanca where Ingrid Bergman's character Ilsa requests a song from Sam the piano player, played by Dooley Wilson. As time goes by became one of the most famous movie themes ever, and it seemed like Dooley Wilson had a guaranteed hit record on his hands, if he could just head into a studio and play it again.
录音禁令的另一个例外是在好莱坞。那里的电影制片厂管弦乐队继续制作电影配乐，但这导致了一些奇怪的事情。以1942年那部最终获得最佳影片奖的电影为例。在《卡萨布兰卡》（Casablanca）中有一个著名的场景，英格丽·褒曼（Ingrid Bergman）饰演的伊尔莎（Ilsa）向杜利·威尔逊（Dooley Wilson）饰演的钢琴家萨姆（Sam）点了一首歌。《时光流逝》（As Time Goes By）成为了有史以来最著名的电影主题曲之一，如果杜利·威尔逊能走进录音棚再录一遍，他似乎就稳拿一张热门唱片了。
Sam. You played it for her, you played for me. Except Dooley Wilson couldn't play it. Instead, the record companies dug deep into their vaults. They dusted off old recordings of his time goes by and re-release them. And when to love a fool, they still say I love you, on that you can rely. Frank Munn's vocal style on this 1931 recording already sounded ancient a decade later. But listeners craved as time goes by so
“萨姆。你为她演奏过，你也为我演奏过。”除了杜利·威尔逊无法演奏它。相反，唱片公司深入挖掘了他们的金库。他们掸去了《时光流逝》的旧录音并重新发行了它们。“当爱上一个傻瓜，他们仍然说我爱你，你可以依靠这一点。”弗兰克·芒恩（Frank Munn）在1931年录音中的演唱风格在十年后听起来已经很古老了。但听众对《时光流逝》的渴望如此
badly that this version hit number three in April 1943. Everyone knew that consumers wouldn't be content with moldy oldies forever. Music can't just stay frozen in time, it has to evolve. And the truth is, it was evolving very rapidly, even though most Americans had no idea. That's because it was all happening in the middle of the night, hidden away in smoky clubs. And when the new sound finally got out, American culture would never be the same. We'll be right back.
强烈，以至于这个版本在1943年4月冲到了第三名。每个人都知道消费者不会永远满足于陈旧的老歌。音乐不能只是冻结在时间里，它必须进化。事实是，它正在迅速进化，尽管大多数美国人对此一无所知。这是因为这一切都发生在深夜，隐藏在烟雾缭绕的俱乐部里。当新的声音最终传出来时，美国文化将永远改变。我们马上回来。
After six months, James C. Petrillo finally offered a proposal for how to end the recording ban. In February 1943, he told the record labels that they would have to pay a royalty directly to the union for each record sold. That money would go into a trust fund for unemployed musicians. The union would hire them to play free public concerts. This fund will not be used for any other purpose, but for the advancement of musical culture. You know, this was a modern solution. Tim Anderson again. It would turn a record into another live performance because you could actually take the residuals that went into the trust fund and then give them to somebody else to play.
六个月后，詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛终于提出了如何结束录音禁令的建议。1943年2月，他告诉唱片公司，他们必须为每张售出的唱片直接向工会支付版税。这笔钱将进入一个为失业音乐家设立的信托基金。工会将雇佣他们进行免费的公共音乐会演出。“这笔基金将不会用于任何其他目的，只会用于促进音乐文化。”你知道，这是一个现代的解决方案。蒂姆·安德森再次说道。“它会将一张唱片变成另一场现场表演，因为你可以真正地将进入信托基金的剩余部分拿出来，然后给其他人去演奏。”
To the three major labels, it was an absurd idea. RCA Victor, Columbia, and Deca rejected the proposal as socialistic. Why should they be contributing to a welfare fund for people who weren't even their employees? So, the band continued. In 1943, the pressure was mounting to record some new songs. But even as the band passed the one year mark, the three major labels stood together. Or so they thought. Their United Front was finally broken, as all but two of the biggest recording companies agreed to Petrillo's terms.
对这三家主要唱片公司来说，这是一个荒谬的想法。RCA Victor、哥伦比亚和迪卡拒绝了这一提议，称其为社会主义行为。为什么他们要为一个甚至不是他们员工的人的福利基金做出贡献？所以，禁令继续。1943年，录制新歌的压力越来越大。但即使禁令超过了一年，这三家主要唱片公司仍然团结一致。或者他们是这么认为的。他们的统一战线最终被打破了，因为除了两家最大的唱片公司外，所有公司都同意了佩特里洛的条款。
Deca was the smallest of the three companies. It didn't have the back catalog that RCA or Columbia did, and by September 1943, its stockpile of recordings was nearly depleted. Deca is running out of money. I mean, they're on the verge of bankruptcy. Writer Mark Myers again. And Deca throws in the towel and Deca signs with the union. They say, fine, we'll pay you that royalty. James Petrillo was ready to gloat. The recent contracts which we have negotiated
迪卡是这三家公司中规模最小的一家。它没有RCA或哥伦比亚那样的过往目录，到1943年9月，它的录音储备几乎耗尽了。“迪卡快没钱了。我的意思是，他们处于破产边缘。”作家马克·迈尔斯再次说道。“迪卡认输了，迪卡与工会签约。他们说，好吧，我们会支付那笔版税。”詹姆斯·佩特里洛准备幸灾乐祸。“我们最近谈判达成的合同
will bring into the federation treasury approximately $3 million per year. But the two biggest labels still refuse to budge. Columbia and RCA, they say, no, we're not going to do that. We think eventually Congress is going to force you guys back to work. Deca, though, was now free to record. And not only Deca, all of a sudden, these little companies sweep in and take full advantage of the fact that Columbia and RCA are off the market.
每年将为联合会国库带来大约300万美元的收入。”但两家最大的唱片公司仍然拒绝让步。哥伦比亚和RCA说：“不，我们不会那样做。我们认为最终国会会强迫你们回去工作。”然而，迪卡现在可以自由录音了。不仅是迪卡，突然之间，这些小公司蜂拥而至，充分利用了哥伦比亚和RCA退出市场的事实。
More than 100 small companies also signed royalty agreements with the Union. Many of them were entirely new labels, entrepreneurs sniffed an opportunity. Perhaps there was now room to muscle in on RCA and Columbia's turf. The question was, who were they going to record? The guaranteed money makers were big bands. Swing had been developed by black big bands in Kansas City more than a decade earlier. By the mid-1930s, white band leaders like Benny Goodman and Arty Shaw had picked it up, and turned it into a crossover phenomenon. For a country anxious over the Depression and a World War, it was the perfect soundtrack.
超过100家小公司也与工会签署了版税协议。其中许多是全新的唱片公司，企业家们嗅到了机会。也许现在有空间挤进RCA和哥伦比亚的地盘了。问题是，他们要录制谁？保证赚钱的是大乐队。摇摆乐（Swing）早在十多年前就由堪萨斯城的黑人大乐队开发出来了。到1930年代中期，像本尼·古德曼和阿蒂·肖（Artie Shaw）这样的白人乐队领队已经掌握了它，并将其变成了一种跨界现象。对于一个因大萧条和世界大战而焦虑的国家来说，这是完美的配乐。
Swing was basically an elixir for society at large. Swing music is designed to cheer people up, to keep people in a good mood, to give people hope. Big Bands held the number one position on the Billboard charts virtually every week since the charts began in 1940. So, it would make sense for these startup labels to record them. Except, they couldn't. They can't record already Shaw.
摇摆乐基本上是整个社会的灵丹妙药。摇摆乐旨在让人们振作起来，保持愉悦的心情，给人们带来希望。自1940年排行榜诞生以来，大乐队几乎每周都占据着公告牌排行榜的第一名。因此，这些初创唱片公司录制他们的作品是有道理的。只不过，他们做不到。他们无法录制肖的音乐。
They can't record Benny-Germann. All these major band leaders are signed to the two labels that are sitting there whittling away waiting for the union to cave so they can't get the big talent. Instead the new companies recorded niche genres, POCA, GOSPIL, and what was then called And you leave me alone, I'm wasting my tears on you. But some label owners knew of another option. As the recording band Trudged On, a group of jazz musicians had been developing something different, a mind-blowing style of music that no one had put on record. This new music had been born out of artistic necessity, because as great as swing was,
他们无法录制本尼·古德曼的音乐。所有这些主要的乐队领队都签约了那两家唱片公司，而那些公司正坐享其成，等着工会屈服，所以他们无法获得这些大牌人才。相反，这些新公司录制了一些小众流派，如波卡、福音音乐，以及当时被称为“你别管我，我在为你浪费眼泪”的音乐。但一些唱片公司老板知道还有另一种选择。随着录音禁令的持续，一群爵士乐手一直在发展一种不同的、令人耳目一新的音乐风格，这是以前从未被录制过的。这种新音乐源于艺术上的必要性，因为尽管摇摆乐很棒，
it could be a little stifling for individual musicians. They weren't hired to express themselves, they were there to serve their audience. The dance band was for background. If you were dancing, your primary focus was the guy or the gal you are dancing with. So while the music could be wonderful and lush and vibrant, it could also feel a little formulaic. Each dance band might have its own style, but that was entirely determined by the band leader.
但对于个人乐手来说，它可能会让人感到有些压抑。他们受雇不是为了表达自我，而是为了服务观众。舞曲乐队是背景音乐。如果你在跳舞，你的主要注意力是你舞伴身上的那个人。所以，虽然音乐可能美妙、丰富且充满活力，但它也可能让人感觉有些刻板。每个舞曲乐队可能有自己的风格，但这完全是由乐队领队决定的。
That band leader's sound took precedence over anybody's individual ego or playing ability. So individuals had to suppress individualism. You had to be part of the larger sound of that band. You had to be an ingredient in the sauce. As an instrumentalist, you may not even get a chance to solo. And if you did land a solo, you played it how the band leader wanted it, or you'd be in trouble. They ran the bands like little companies, like corporations, where things had to be done
乐队领队的声音高于任何个人的自我或演奏能力。因此，个人必须压抑个性。你必须成为乐队宏大声音的一部分。你必须是酱汁中的一种配料。作为一名乐器演奏家，你甚至可能没有机会独奏。即使你真的获得了独奏机会，你也必须按照乐队领队想要的方式演奏，否则你就会有麻烦。他们像经营小公司或大企业一样经营乐队，事情必须以
a certain way, and if you didn't like it, you got fired, and if you didn't play right, you got fired. So there were rigid rules for those big bands. So precarity for musicians was part and parcel of the job. Historian Robin D. G. Kelly, and so the glamour of waking up and being creative and coming up with something new and expanding their horizons of art, that's something that most musicians don't even have to luxury to do, even if that's what inspired them in the first place. But not every jazz musician in the early 40s could settle for a life of big band conformity. The trumpet player Dizzy Gillespie was one artist who yearned for something more. His way of thinking wasn't as rigid.
某种方式完成，如果你不喜欢，你就会被解雇；如果你演奏得不对，你也会被解雇。所以这些大乐队有严格的规定。因此，乐手的不稳定性是这份工作的一部分。历史学家罗宾·D·G·凯利说，那种醒来后进行创作、想出新点子并拓宽艺术视野的魅力，是大多数乐手甚至没有奢侈去享受的，即使这正是最初激励他们的东西。但并不是40年代初的每一位爵士乐手都能满足于大乐队那种循规蹈矩的生活。小号手迪兹·吉莱斯皮就是一位渴望更多东西的艺术家。他的思维方式并不那么僵化。
I mean, he was thinking more of himself as an individual. How can I create a new language? How can I create a new sound?" And he wasn't the only musician brimming with ideas. There was an idiosyncratic piano player named Philoneus Monk, an inventive percussionist named Kenny Clark, and a bluesy saxophoneist from Kansas City, Charlie Parker. But these musicians needed a space to try out their new ideas. That wasn't going to happen in their day job in the big band. So they had to do it off the clock. You know, when they're not playing in the bands or they have off nights, they're going
我的意思是，他更多地把自己视为一个个体。“我怎样才能创造一种新的语言？我怎样才能创造一种新的声音？”而且他并不是唯一一个充满想法的乐手。还有一位特立独行的钢琴家名叫塞隆尼斯·蒙克，一位富有创造力的打击乐手名叫肯尼·克拉克，以及一位来自堪萨斯城的蓝调萨克斯手查理·帕克。但这些乐手需要一个空间来尝试他们的新想法。这在他们大乐队的日常工作中是不可能实现的。所以他们必须在工作之余去做。你知道，当他们不在乐队演奏或者有休息的晚上时，他们会
to after hours clubs, you know, you had Mittens in Harlem and you had Monroe's uptown. These are the clubs where a revolution, a slow revolution in music was taken in place, where musicians will come and jam. The jam sessions might not start until one or two in the morning. And when you walk in, you see a room full of both musicians sitting ready to play
去下班后的俱乐部，你知道，哈莱姆区有米滕斯俱乐部，上城区有门罗俱乐部。这些俱乐部是音乐革命——一场缓慢的革命——发生的地方，乐手们会来这里即兴演奏。即兴演奏会可能要到凌晨一两点才开始。当你走进去时，你会看到房间里坐满了准备演奏的乐手，
and some hangers on who just love the music. People are talking, people are laughing, and on the bandstand you'd see Thelonius Monk, you'd see Kenny Clark, and they'd be up there calling tunes. They could play all the things you are. Nice work if you can get it. All these different songs people think they know, and then they would take them on a journey. And the music is raising the hairs on the backs of your arms. Dizzy Gillespie and Charlie Parker might be up there,
还有一些只是热爱音乐的追随者。人们在交谈，人们在欢笑，在舞台上你会看到塞隆尼斯·蒙克，你会看到肯尼·克拉克，他们会在那里点歌。他们可以演奏《All the Things You Are》、《Nice Work If You Can Get It》。所有这些人们以为自己熟悉的歌曲，然后他们会带你踏上一段旅程。音乐让你手臂上的汗毛都竖起来了。迪兹·吉莱斯皮和查理·帕克可能会在那里，
experimenting with strange harmonies and dissonant sounds. Musicians would be either thrilled by it, excited, or confused. In those who are confused sometimes would have to sit down and they couldn't handle it. Those left standing might go on for hours, daring each other to take the music farther and farther out there. People would be cheering and rooting on their favorite saxophonist to go after the other one. Whoa, yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
尝试奇怪的和声和不和谐的声音。乐手们要么会为此感到兴奋、激动，要么会感到困惑。那些感到困惑的人有时不得不坐下来，因为他们无法接受。而那些站着的人可能会持续演奏几个小时，互相挑战，把音乐推向更远的地方。人们会欢呼，为他们最喜欢的萨克斯手加油，让他去挑战另一个。哇，耶，耶。耶，耶。耶。耶。
It's an environment not unlike a boxing arena. In the illegal boxing arena where two people are battling it out. The solo might go on for 10 minutes. I mean, the longer somebody could play, the more wild the audience would get. Virtuosity was a virtue. They wanted to play faster.
这环境就像一个拳击场。在一个非法的拳击场里，两个人正在进行较量。独奏可能会持续10分钟。我的意思是，一个人演奏的时间越长，观众就会越疯狂。精湛的技艺是一种美德。他们想演奏得更快。
Very, very fast, too fast to dance to. And they are, you know, shooting out ideas that are like lightning bolts. Max Roacher, Kenny Clark, might drop in a couple of bombs on the snare and then hit the symbol once, and then come back and hit the symbol twice. And, you know, there's a rhythm there, but it's fracturing. It's almost like looking at a cubist painting. All this created a certain kind of sense of freedom during these moments of joy. You know, they're not necessarily conscious attempts to make new music.
非常、非常快，快到无法跳舞。而且，你知道，他们像闪电一样迸发出各种想法。马克斯·罗奇、肯尼·克拉克可能会在小鼓上投下几颗“炸弹”，然后敲击一次镲片，接着回来敲击两次镲片。而且，你知道，那里有一种节奏，但它是破碎的。这几乎就像在看一幅立体派绘画。所有这些在这些欢乐的时刻创造了一种自由感。你知道，这并不一定是刻意尝试去创作新音乐。
They're just conscious attempts to be free. Parker, Gillespie, Monk and the other innovators, they didn't have a special name for this radical new sound they developed. But years later, it would come to be called Bebop. This music's being played, audiences going nuts, but as soon as they go home, they need to come back to the club to hear it again. That's because there were no records made of all that wild experimentation in 1942 or 1943. For many jazz fans, Petrillo's recording band represents a dark age where the evolution of our greatest artists
他们只是刻意尝试去获得自由。帕克、吉莱斯皮、蒙克和其他创新者，他们并没有为这种他们开发的激进新声音起一个特别的名字。但多年后，它被称为“比波普”（Bebop）。这种音乐正在演奏，观众们为之疯狂，但他们一回家，就需要回到俱乐部再次聆听。这是因为在1942年或1943年，所有那些疯狂的实验都没有被录制下来。对于许多爵士乐迷来说，佩特里洛的录音禁令代表了一个黑暗时代，我们最伟大艺术家的演变
is erased from history. That is a lost period of time when it comes to bebop. But to view the recording band purely as a tragedy for jazz is way too simplistic. The truth is, bebop probably wouldn't have been recorded even without the band. The Big Three record companies weren't in the business of recording unproven talents like Charlie Parker, who played at five in the morning at Harlan Clubs. But thanks to the recording band, the big three labels now had a whole lot of competition. Once Deca agreed to the union's terms, all these independent companies came out the wood works.
从历史上被抹去了。就比波普而言，那是一段失落的时期。但如果仅仅把录音禁令视为爵士乐的悲剧，那就太简单了。事实是，即使没有禁令，比波普可能也不会被录制。三大唱片公司并不从事录制像查理·帕克这样在哈莱姆俱乐部凌晨五点演奏的未经验证的人才的业务。但多亏了录音禁令，三大唱片公司现在面临着巨大的竞争。一旦迪卡唱片公司同意了工会的条款，所有这些独立公司都如雨后春笋般涌现出来。
Labels like Apollo, Guild, Musicraft, Commodore Label, Dial, Signature, Blue Note, Savoy, Deluxe, Commodore label, dial, signature, blue note, Savoy, Deluxe, many were brand new, others were reinvigorated. That was a real new development that shaped the future of jazz. Those small labels became the jazz labels. These labels couldn't record the established band leaders like Duke Ellington and Benny Goodman. So they took a chance on the guys playing a wild, labels couldn't record the established band leaders like Duke Ellington and Benny Goodman.
像阿波罗、公会、音乐工艺、准将唱片、戴尔、签名、蓝调之音、萨伏伊、豪华等唱片公司，许多是全新的，另一些则重获新生。这是一个真正塑造了爵士乐未来的新发展。那些小型唱片公司成为了爵士乐唱片公司。这些公司无法录制像艾灵顿公爵和本尼·古德曼这样已成名的乐队领队。所以他们冒险录制了那些演奏狂野音乐的人，这些公司无法录制像艾灵顿公爵和本尼·古德曼这样已成名的乐队领队。
So they took a chance on the guys playing a wild, sophisticated new music in after-hours clubs. And that's when the revolution kicks into high gear. On February 16th, 1944, Apollo Records held its very first recording session in New York City. In the studio that day, Bridezi Gillespie, Max Roach, saxophone, and Coleman Hawkins and others. And what they came up with would be the first commercial recording of Bebop.
所以他们冒险录制了那些在下班后俱乐部演奏狂野、复杂新音乐的人。就在那时，革命进入了高潮。1944年2月16日，阿波罗唱片公司在纽约市举行了第一次录音会议。那天在录音室里有迪兹·吉莱斯皮、马克斯·罗奇、萨克斯手科尔曼·霍金斯等人。他们创作出的作品成为了比波普的第一张商业录音。
They're basically turning jam session and all the experimental music into these records and selling them. But that was only the beginning. One very famous recording is Coco, which is Charlie Parker, Dizzy Gillespie. It is kind of a clinic in bebot music in terms of virtuosity and harmonies. In Coco, Charlie Parker takes the chord changes to another song,
他们基本上是将即兴演奏会和所有实验性音乐变成唱片并进行销售。但这仅仅是个开始。一张非常著名的唱片是《Coco》，由查理·帕克和迪兹·吉莱斯皮录制。就精湛技艺和和声而言，它堪称比波普音乐的教科书。在《Coco》中，查理·帕克采用了另一首歌的和弦进行，
a standard called Cherokee, and he invents a completely new melody on top of it. That's a revolutionary thing. It's like taking the same house, but changing all the furniture. Now you hear the drums completely changed, Max Roach. He's playing it three times as fast as it should be played. He's playing it three times as fast as it should be played Wow Coco is so fast and so complex that it even stymied Miles Davis
一首名为《Cherokee》的标准曲，并在其上发明了一种全新的旋律。这是一件革命性的事情。这就像是保留了同一栋房子，但更换了所有的家具。现在你听到鼓声完全变了，马克斯·罗奇。他演奏的速度比正常速度快了三倍。他演奏的速度比正常速度快了三倍。哇，《Coco》太快、太复杂了，甚至让迈尔斯·戴维斯都感到困惑。
He was supposed to play on the session, but he just couldn't keep up I mean the intricacy and the density. I mean keep in mind other than that melodic line that sets up the song. All the rest of it's made up, almost spot, right there. I mean it's inconceivable. So many years later, that's still fresh, it's still exciting, it's still dynamic, and it's still a wonderment. Until this point, Bebop had felt like a secret language that only a handful of artists knew. Even other jazz musicians who had seen Parker and Gillespie play hadn't been able to figure
他本应参加这次录音，但他根本跟不上。我的意思是那种复杂性和密度。请记住，除了设定歌曲的那条旋律线之外，其余部分都是即兴创作的，几乎是当场完成的。我的意思是这简直不可思议。多年以后，它依然新鲜，依然令人兴奋，依然充满活力，依然令人惊叹。直到这一点，比波普感觉就像只有少数艺术家才知道的秘密语言。即使是看过帕克和吉莱斯皮演奏的其他爵士乐手也无法弄清楚
out what they were actually doing, but now, they could take a record like Coco home with them and put it on their phonographs and slow it down and start to write down what they were actually doing. But now, they could take a record like Coco home with them and put it on their phone graphs and slow it down and start to write down what they were hearing. Ah, that's what Dizzy Gillespie's doing there. Ah, I see. That's what Charlie Parker's doing with that court. So they could sort of unravel the recipe to Bebop once these records were made. And with that, this new sound became emulated all over. And the trajectory of jazz was transformed. Bebop opened up space for new harmonization. You get more dissonance and more abstraction.
他们到底在做什么，但现在，他们可以把像《Coco》这样的唱片带回家，放在留声机上放慢速度，开始写下他们到底在做什么。但现在，他们可以把像《Coco》这样的唱片带回家，放在留声机上放慢速度，开始写下他们听到的内容。“啊，原来迪兹·吉莱斯皮在那里是这么做的。啊，我明白了。原来查理·帕克用那个和弦是这么做的。”所以一旦这些唱片制作出来，他们就能解开比波普的秘方。随之，这种新声音在各地被效仿。爵士乐的轨迹被改变了。比波普为新的和声开辟了空间。你得到了更多的不和谐音和更多的抽象感。
The rhythm change dramatically, pretty much forever. That becomes a standard. It doesn't go back to the old way. The old style of a rigid big band under the control of a single leader was giving way to a new era. All of a sudden it's not about one person, it's about everybody, and it's about what they're bringing to it. Everybody gets a turn. Everybody gets a solo. The whole game was to sound as individual as possible and to create your own musical identity. But even as bebop started to spread, the recording band was still going against the two
节奏发生了巨大的变化，几乎是永久性的。这成为了一种标准。它不会回到旧的方式。在单一领队控制下的僵化大乐队的旧风格正在让位于一个新时代。突然之间，这不再是一个人的事，而是关于每个人，关于他们带来了什么。每个人都有机会。每个人都有独奏机会。整个游戏的规则就是听起来尽可能有个性，并创造你自己的音乐身份。但即使比波普开始传播，录音禁令仍然在对抗那两家
biggest companies. In October 1944, President Roosevelt personally asked James C. Petrilo to end it. Petrilo rebuffed even him. With Deca and the new small labels gaining ground, RCA and Colombia realized they could no longer wait it out. So, on November 11, 1944, they surrendered. The labels signed an agreement accepting the union's terms for three years. After more than 27 months, the recording band was finally over. James Caesar Petrillo had won. Temporarily. I think he'd temporarily win, but they eventually lose the war over records.
最大的公司。1944年10月，罗斯福总统亲自要求詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛结束禁令。佩特里洛连他也拒绝了。随着迪卡唱片公司和新的小型唱片公司站稳脚跟，RCA和哥伦比亚唱片公司意识到他们不能再拖下去了。于是，1944年11月11日，他们投降了。这些唱片公司签署了一项协议，接受了工会为期三年的条款。在持续了27个多月后，录音禁令终于结束了。詹姆斯·凯撒·佩特里洛赢了。暂时地。我认为他只是暂时赢了，但他们最终输掉了关于唱片的战争。
In 1946, Congress passed a bill called the LIA Act. It was designed explicitly to weaken the American Federation of Musicians and was more commonly known as the Anti-Patrillo Act. Hey, look, we don't want this to ever happen again and we're gonna defame the GFM and they effectively defame them. The next year came the Taft Heartly Act, which diminished the power of all unions.
1946年，国会通过了一项名为《利亚法案》（Lea Act）的法案。它明确旨在削弱美国音乐家联合会，通常被称为“反佩特里洛法案”。嘿，听着，我们不希望这种情况再次发生，我们要诋毁美国音乐家联合会，他们有效地诋毁了他们。第二年，塔夫脱-哈特利法案出台，削弱了所有工会的力量。
Washington was in the midst of a full anti-labor backlash. Meanwhile, new technological advances were coming that filled the union with anxiety. What would television and FM radio mean for musicians? Would they lead to more opportunities or more displacement? These questions were still unanswered when the Union's agreement with the record labels expired at the end of 1947. That's when Petrilo called for another band. He asked when I'd record again.
华盛顿正处于全面反劳工浪潮之中。与此同时，新的技术进步即将到来，这让工会充满了焦虑。电视和调频广播对音乐家意味着什么？它们会导致更多的机会还是更多的流离失所？当工会与唱片公司的协议在1947年底到期时，这些问题仍未得到解答。就在那时，佩特里洛发起了另一次禁令。他问我什么时候再录音。
I said Petrilo's the boss. I've got the record band blues. This is Dina Washington's song record band blues. Yes, I've got those record band blues. This is Dina Washington's song, Record Band Blues. The record companies were better prepared in 1948. The band didn't last nearly as long this time. The AFM won some of its demands, but even Petrilo could see where things were headed. You basically says in 48 industry is taken over.
我说佩特里洛是老板。我有“录音禁令蓝调”。这是迪娜·华盛顿的歌《录音禁令蓝调》。是的，我有那些“录音禁令蓝调”。这是迪娜·华盛顿的歌《录音禁令蓝调》。唱片公司在1948年做了更好的准备。这次禁令持续的时间远没有那么长。美国音乐家联合会赢得了一些要求，但即使是佩特里洛也能看出事情的发展方向。他在48年基本上说行业已经被接管了。
They've taken the reins. I'm not going to lie to you guys. We're no longer in the leading position. The solutions that James C. Patrillo fought for were innovative, but ultimately inadequate. Using royalties to pay for some free concerts wouldn't save musicians jobs. The issues that he raised in 1942 never really got settled.
他们已经掌握了缰绳。我不会对你们撒谎。我们不再处于领先地位。詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛所争取的解决方案是创新的，但最终是不够的。利用版税来支付一些免费音乐会并不能挽救音乐家的工作。他在1942年提出的问题从未真正得到解决。
Decades later, they popped up again with the rise of Napster and streaming services like Spotify. In the same questions or ask, how are you going to compensate the content providers? We still have a long ways to go to talk about fair and just compensation. We need to think about what the norms of progress are, anytime that we disrupt a so-called industry through tech, and displace a bunch of people and a bunch of workers, we were not thinking about the issues of ethics. We're thinking about how can we do this more efficiently and at less cost, you know, then we'll grow our profit margins. The victories of the recording band may have been temporary and insufficient, you know, then we'll grow our profit margins.
几十年后，随着Napster和Spotify等流媒体服务的兴起，这些问题再次出现。同样的问题被问及：你打算如何补偿内容提供者？在谈论公平公正的补偿方面，我们还有很长的路要走。我们需要思考什么是进步的准则，每当我们通过技术颠覆所谓的行业，并取代一群人和一群工人时，我们并没有考虑伦理问题。我们考虑的是如何以更低的成本更高效地完成这项工作，你知道，然后我们就会增加利润率。录音禁令的胜利可能是暂时的且不足的，你知道，然后我们就会增加利润率。
The victories of the recording band may have been temporary and insufficient, but the impact of bebop was permanent and profound, and not only within the world of jazz. As the recording spread after the war, bebop began what Ralph Ellison called a revolution in culture. It spilled into art and literature. It altered how people spoke and dressed, and it became a soundtrack to the struggle for civil rights. Duke Gellington called this music the Marcus Garvey Extension.
录音禁令的胜利可能是暂时的且不足的，但比波普的影响是永久且深远的，而且不仅仅是在爵士乐界。随着录音在战后传播，比波普开始了拉尔夫·埃里森所说的文化革命。它蔓延到艺术和文学领域。它改变了人们说话和穿衣的方式，并成为民权斗争的配乐。艾灵顿公爵称这种音乐为“马库斯·加维的延伸”。
This is a music with politics, a music that caused for feet of all black people that celebrates blackness. This wasn't at all what James C. Petrilo had in mind. He'd fought to keep black musicians out of his local in Chicago, but it may be his recording band's greatest legacy. If it wasn't for the band and these small record labels, Charlie Parker, Dizzy Gillespie, Kenny Clark, Philonea Monk, might never have been
这是一种带有政治色彩的音乐，一种呼吁所有黑人团结起来、庆祝黑人身份的音乐。这根本不是詹姆斯·C·佩特里洛所想的。他曾努力将黑人音乐家拒之于他在芝加哥的工会分部之外，但这可能是他录音禁令留下的最大遗产。如果不是因为禁令以及这些小型唱片公司，查理·帕克、迪兹·吉莱斯皮、肯尼·克拉克、塞隆尼斯·蒙克可能永远不会
known. Because if there was no band, RCA, Columbia, and Deca would have continued to control the market, they wouldn't have allowed this music to surface. Never would have become a thing. And modern jazz might not have existed at all. The episode of One Year was written and produced by Evan Chong. It was edited by me, Josh Levine, and Derek Chong, Slate's senior supervising producer of narrative podcasts. Additional production came from Sophie Summergrad and Sam Ken.
为人所知。因为如果没有禁令，RCA、哥伦比亚和迪卡唱片公司将继续控制市场，他们不会允许这种音乐浮出水面。它永远不会成为一种潮流。现代爵士乐可能根本就不会存在。《One Year》的这一集由埃文·钟撰写和制作。由我、乔什·莱文和斯莱特叙事播客的高级监督制片人德里克·钟编辑。额外的制作来自索菲·萨默格拉德和萨姆·肯。
Our senior technical director is Mary Jacob. Holly Allen created the artwork for this season. The audio of the fanatogram came from first sounds. Tim Anderson's book is called Making Easy Listening. Mark Myers is the author of Why Jazz Happened. And Robin D. G. Kelly's biography of Thelonius Muck is called Thelonius Muck, the life and times of an American original.
我们的高级技术总监是玛丽·雅各布。霍莉·艾伦为本季创作了艺术作品。Fanatogram的音频来自First Sounds。蒂姆·安德森的书名为《Making Easy Listening》。马克·迈尔斯是《Why Jazz Happened》的作者。罗宾·D·G·凯利的塞隆尼斯·蒙克传记名为《Thelonious Monk: The Life and Times of an American Original》。
You can send us feedback and ideas and memories from 1942 at 1yearatslate.com and you can call us on the 1 year hotline at 203-343-0777. We'd love to hear from you. Special thanks to Christina Cauterucci, Madeline Ducharm, Susan Matthews, Soul Worthen, Bill Kerry, Katie Rayford, Ben Richmond, Caitlin Schneider, Cleo Levin, Seth Brown, Rachel Strom, and Alicia Montgomery, Slates VP of Audio. Thanks for listening. We'll be back next week with more from 1942. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以通过1yearatslate.com向我们发送反馈、想法和1942年的记忆，也可以拨打我们的1年热线203-343-0777。我们很乐意听到你的声音。特别感谢克里斯蒂娜·考特鲁奇、马德琳·杜查姆、苏珊·马修斯、索尔·沃森、比尔·凯里、凯蒂·雷福德、本·里士满、凯特琳·施耐德、克莱奥·莱文、塞斯·布朗、雷切尔·斯特罗姆和斯莱特音频副总裁艾丽西亚·蒙哥马利。感谢收听。下周我们将带来更多1942年的内容。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。